all right let's get right into audience
questions the first one hey David I am
sick and tired of this daylight saving
time BS is it finally time to get rid of
daylight savings time
people often ask this but really what
they mean is do we want to make daylight
savings time permanent I believe that it
would be a good idea to stop changing
the clocks and honestly I'm actually up
for either way either getting rid of DST
or making DST permanent but my
preference would be not to end DST but
to stay on it for the entire year so
remember we just ended DST so now that
DST is over we have the Sun coming up an
hour earlier and we have the Sun setting
an hour earlier
I want it darker earlier when I'm trying
to sleep I don't need the Sun up like
for example this week in Boston now the
Sun Sun rises officially like 6 26 22 I
think it was today 6 22 in the morning
I'm not up that early and if I am I'm
okay with it being dark still if I'm up
at 622 in the morning I would much
rather a 5:30 sunset then a 4:30 sunset
and instead which is what we have this
week in Boston a 4:30 official sunset
and instead let it be darker earlier
when I'm trying to sleep now I know that
this doesn't apply to everybody's
schedule but there are way more people
who are awake at 5:30 p.m. then there
are at 6:15 in the morning although I
know many people get up that early I
understand I'm not ignoring you and if
you want to make an energy argument by
not needing the lights until an hour
later when there are many more people
awake that would turn on a light if it's
dark at 4:30 you have a huge effective
net energy savings that's number one
there are all sorts of medical claims
that are attributed to the switch the
switch itself versus it being light out
earlier versus later are sort of two
different categories but there are
questions about increased car crashes
workplace accidents mood and all sorts
of others
I think that there's probably you know
you need to look into detail to figure
out how many of them are just for the
day or two after the switch happens
meaning two to four days out of the year
and how many are sort of permanent by
having the Sun set earlier during the
winter you certainly have more people
commuting home in the dark when you end
DST my guess is that that also leads to
more car accidents so thirty-six states
have introduced legislation to stop the
time change some of those say we will
stay on standard time all year others
say we will stay on DST excuse me all
year
the main argument that I hear against
permanent daylight saving is people who
get up earlier are going to get up in
the dark and that's not good
I think that that argument with peace
and love to all of the early risers I
think that that argument is more than
outdone by the increased safety of more
people getting to commute home in
daylight the increased environmental
advantage of not needing to turn on
lights until an hour later in the
afternoon when many more people are
awake so I am ready to say here today
not end DST make DST permanent I want
that extra hour in the afternoon all
year round much of the world we listen
in Argentina in winter I think in bonus
itis sometimes it like 7:30 it's still
pretty dark out it's fine people get
used to it in northwestern Spain for
other reasons because of they're on the
wrong timezone but it doesn't matter in
northwestern Spain where my stepmoms
from in Santiago de Compostela it often
the Sun I think even at 8 p.m. sometimes
during summer it's I'm sorry 8 a.m.
until 8 a.m. it's still pretty dark but
then you get sunlight until like 9:45 in
summer and it's a beautiful thing let's
get on permanent DST tell me if I'm
wrong please don't cancel me if this
goes against your preconceived notion of
the issue I'm just telling you what I
think at the time